the Mekong River in its natural glory
but for how long the first signs of
change downriver from luang prabang in
laos a bridge is being built for one of
Asia's most controversial dam
construction projects we're traveling on
a motor boat towards the Shia buried em
the source of the controversy we don't
know how close will get to the
construction site since we're not
licensed to film there but what do the
people here know they say construction
has been underway for two years mostly
of roads leading to the site who'd you
like what go sure says this man the
landscape here has changed significantly
fourteen hundred kilometers downstream
the river branches out in several
directions and takes a 20-metre plunge
measured by the volume of water it's the
world's largest waterfall
we continue our journey to another dam
construction project Laos is hoping to
export hydroelectric power it wants to
become the battery of Asia
the country plans to dam up this branch
of the river to make way for a
hydropower plant for now the fisherman's
wooden traps are still set up many fish
swim thousands of kilometers from the
estuary to the headwaters fishermen
PETMAN even knows how important it is
for fish to move unimpeded once the dam
is built he says he knows for certain
that his traps will be flooded well Bob
what I'd it when the dam gets built here
it'll be the end of fishing the Mekong
is home to the largest variety of fish
species in the world for now at least 50
kilometres further south the Mekong
flows through Cambodia during the rainy
season the river stretches to several
kilometers wide the water flows over the
treetops pulling them to one side we're
traveling with a local Cambodian
conservationist he's most worried about
the large dam project in Laos vava me
unless I again gaetano vijaya booty dam
will change the entire ecosystem the
less water means fewer fish what I
the country's downstream from lowes
especially Cambodia and Vietnam are
fighting tooth and nail to prevent the
dam project from going ahead here a
tourists are on the lookout for dolphins
but sightings in the Mekong River are
increasingly rare we're in crotty in
Cambodia we catch sight of leaping fish
shortly afterwards a dolphin appears
after years of being hunted the dolphin
stock was largely depleted the dams now
being planned present an additional
threat to these mammals Gerard Ryan is a
dolphin researcher he uses special
camera equipment to track the dolphin
population in the area he fears that if
the dam in Laos is built more will
follow there are currently plans for 10
more dams along the river in Cambodia
there are two dams planned within
dolphin habitat one at Sambora and one
at stone train and another one just
upstream danza hong in southern lao and
i think any of those dams could have a
very significant impact on this
population and potentially wipe it out
even
river traffic is heavy close to
cambodia's capital city pan on penn the
mekong is the lifeblood of the country
people here get eighty percent of their
protein from fish that's why Cambodians
are so concerned about the effect the
dam will have on the mekong ecosystem I
got guy diamond trim Hong Kong is the
head of a state-owned fishing operation
in plum pen he's been campaigning for
construction to be pushed back by ten
years to monitor the effects on fish
look I'm Tom getting like that young if
the giant worried am is built the fish
will no longer be able to migrate is
needed la fiamma Mike listen and then we
won't have enough fish I know get your
abundant ASAP mito is located in the
Mekong Delta region in Vietnam 2,000
kilometers downstream from the dam
planned in Laos but people here are
worried too late on buck is a scientist
studying fish stocks he complains that
louse isn't cooperating with the
country's further downstream we have a
need for further study so that we know
more details but so far i do not think
they have considered the effects the dam
will have on neighboring countries
voting louse is following in the
footsteps of China which over the years
has built several dams on the Mekong
River
however they don't go in detail our
specific construction so they don't tell
you the details I from my point of view
I don't think they tell us in detail
it's a politically sensitive topic the
Mekong River flows through six countries
tensions between countries closer to the
mouth of the river and those closer to
the source are already brewing back in
Laos we return to the G ibori damn four
years Louis has maintained that the dam
is not yet under construction but we're
not allowed on land one news agency
however did manage to take pictures they
show that large-scale construction has
been underway for some time and
meanwhile construction has officially
started studies have reportedly
confirmed the safety of the project a
claim disputed by conservationists
we head back down the river fearing that
within a few years we may no longer be
able to behold its natural beauty
you
you